you know we're the crazy on your radar
did you know a lot about them no I
really didn't know very much about them
at all I'd I'd heard of them kind of
vaguely but the the you know they're
obviously a huge deal in the UK and
everyone kind of knows about them there
but in Australia where I grew up it
wasn't the myth wasn't quite as
prevalent you know did you start to do a
lot of research when you found out you
were gonna be playing Francis yeah I did
but I was also I was kind of careful
about it because I think there are so
many stories out there about them and
I'm sure some of them are true and I'm
sure some of them are absolute rubbish
and it was kind of I didn't want to kind
of I didn't want to sort of get bogged
down with all of that different kind of
conflicting information so it was more
about talking to Brian about it really
and you know he'd kind of picked the the
parts of the story that he wanted to use
and I was just sort of I trusted him
enough to kind of go along with with his
version of the story what do you think
it was that she was so attracted to the
bad boy knowing that he was the bad boy
yeah um I think you know she says at the
beginning of the film that when she's on
her first date with Reggie she says I I
I'll do anything to get out of the East
End I don't just want to you know push a
pram and be haggling with the butcher
she doesn't want to be a housewife
essentially and I think when she first
meets him she sees something sort of
glamorous and exciting about him and she
feels like maybe he'll be her escape
from that that world and then obviously
you know I think she kind of turns a
blind eye to the darker side of his
personality at first and then obviously
she can't she can't ignore it forever
and that's what tears in a part in hand
very tragic for sure okay let's just
talk about Tom Hardy my goodness I mean
how did this man pull this off what was
no idea I have no idea we pulled it off
I think you did an excellent job but I I
just I don't think I could even begin to
to do something like what he did in this
film it was really impressive okay well
let's talk about first off are you
acting opposite tom as Reggie right tell
me a little bit about that um that was
sort of
that was that clicked into place a lot
quicker for me it was a lot more I knew
what the formula was with our
relationship a bit more that was easy
and kind of natural for me and it made
sense to me you know their storyline was
sort of a bit more I just I kind of knew
exactly how to approach that
relationship Francis's relationship with
Ron was was a different story completely
I actually think that they're more I
mean they're very very different
personalities but they're actually they
have a little more in common than
Francis does with with Reggie because
they're both operating on another kind
of level of consciousness they're both
like a little bit Spacey and a little
bit out there and acting opposite tom as
ron was a little more difficult to
figure out you know I kind of had to be
on my toes a little bit more he would
ad-lib a lot and it was fun actually it
was probably even more fun acting with
him as Ron just because I never knew
what was going to happen see that's
really interesting that you say that
because as I'm watching the film my
first question to Tom Hardy is going to
be who is more fun or more challenging
Ahana Reggie and as an audience you know
you're watching I think I hear ed she's
probably so easy you know but I think
that Ron was probably very difficult for
him it's yeah that you say that yeah
made it to me it's like working with two
different actors yeah tell me about that
process for you because I'm sure you've
never done that before I've even worked
with an actor he's blank - no I haven't
and I think you completely hit the nail
on the head it's you know a few people
have asked me if it was really
challenging for me and if it was
confusing but honestly he did such a
good job of clearly defining each of
these characters that you know we shot
in a weird way obviously we would shoot
with him as Reggie and then shoot with
him as Ron so technically it was a bit
strange but other than that it was like
working with two different actors so it
was kind of it wasn't too complicated
for me tell me a little bit about even
you standing by as an actor watching
that fight scene what's that like that
was very that was very intense I mean it
was it was Tom fighting with Jacob who's
his stunt double but who also would play
whatever role Tom wasn't playing
at the time and Jacob was so much a part
of the film that watching the film the
first time it was actually like oh
where's Jacob why isn't he in it you
know which was was kind of bizarre
because he was such an important person
on set um so really it was it was just
it was them fighting and it was Tom was
Reggie first and then he switched into
Ron and Jacob would play whoever he
wasn't playing but really it was it was
a brutal fight but they were really
really going for it yeah you know you
obviously get a ton of scripts you've
done so much the great stuff and
everything but when you got this one
what was it about it that you thought
wow I just gotta do this it's really
it's difficult for me to sort of express
verbally because it's so much about gut
instinct I just thought it wasn't
incredibly I mean it's a cool script and
it's a really interesting script but I
think that Francis was a really
beautifully written character and it was
yeah it was just that gut feeling of I
want to I want to bring this person to
life I don't know what it is but I just
want to be a part of this and also
obviously tom was attached at that point
and that was that was a big draw for me
because I've been a big fan of his for a
long time
yeah don't send me leave just a little
bit about your saying being a fan of his
I mean his movies early every every
movie does he just steps it up with each
other
oh he's gonna dog this I think there are
some films of his that you've enjoyed
watching and why why do you think it's
great actor well I I watched I stupidly
actually watched Locke the night before
we started shooting and I just I watched
it I went to see it at the cinema with a
friend and I was like oh no I don't know
how I'm gonna be able to sort of keep up
with this person because he's just so
engaging bronson as well as like one of
my one of my favorite films anyway but i
don't know what makes him so good i
think part of it is just you know a lot
of it is just god-given talent but i
think part of it is the fact that he
really really cares about what he's
doing and he never phones it in and he
just wants the work to be really good
and i love it's so nice being around
that energy when you're making a film
cuz it makes you up your game yeah is it
a daunting experience or even more
pressure when you play somebody who
really lived yeah I think it is
definitely um I think maybe that was
slightly
less pressure on me just because Francis
is an even more mysterious figure than
the crazy you know there's a lot less
information out there about her so I
didn't I didn't have this strong idea of
her in my head I was able to kind of
find bits and pieces and figure it out
with Brian and then kind of create my
own version of her but definitely you
know like I said this Brian said that
this is his fairytale version of the
story and we can't really know what
actually transpired and what was true
and I don't know what she was like in
real life but I do hope that I was able
to kind of do her justice and sort of
capture her spirit to some degree oh you
did I mean my heart went out to you like
music I don't know it's the same Lee you
got to wear some really great costumes
like yeah awesome funny a little bit
about the clothing cuz you know a lot a
lot of people or girls can can pull that
off you like that you were just like in
that mode
yeah I love I mean the 60s is one of my
favorite eras profession so that was
kind of a dream for me that was really
lovely and also it's I mean Caroline our
costume designer was incredible she has
such an amazing eye and she had really
great tailors so everything was just
kind of perfectly fitted and it was
great it was a nice kind of that was a
really enjoyable you know sort of light
fun part of making the film it was a
nice balance to sort of the dark subject
matter of the story yeah I was going to
ask when you're on a set like that and
you've got such an intense actor playing
against you is there time for levity off
the set yeah absolutely I think I was
really glad to um to find out that Tom's
not not a method actor I mean he was he
was sort of joking around as Ron in
between takes but it's very different to
you know to say someone who's entirely
in character the whole time I've that's
not me at all I can't I think I would
lose my mind if I tried to stay in
character so it's nice to be able to to
sort of have jokes in between takes and
it was a very it was a really easy cast
and crew um and I feel like it was it
was really fun to make the film and even
when we were working on these really
dark scenes we had a really good time
stuff and then Brian why was he the
right guy to direct this film I mean
he's just an angel for sadness but I I
think he wrote such an incredible script
and I always I always feel more
comfortable being directed by someone
who's written the script that I love
because I know that you know it's his
it's his vision on the page that
attracted me to the story so to know
that it's not going to change too much
from that is very comforting you know I
trusted him with the story because he
wrote the story so what's next what are
we going to see from you next um I'm not
sure yet I'm kind of trying to be
patient I guess and just looking for
that you know I I loved making this film
so much and I want to make sure that the
next thing I do is something that I that
I care about this much